while commuters head into our cities
every day a different kind of traveler
is heading out to towns and villages
carrying drugs Sky News has previously
investigated how so-called county lines
work drug runners are controlled through
fear
take the stuff I deliver it I give it to
them and I leave I don't even talk to
them because I'm scared of that
bad people and often it's children who
are coerced as mules one of the dealer's
actually stabbed me because I've got
walked so hang on you got robbed and you
went back and you said I have got the
drug so he stabbed you what to punish
you yeah in 2018 the government invested
3.6 million pounds to set up a central
specialist unit to combat county lines
but today's report but the police
Inspectorate says more should be done to
prosecute gangs under the modern slavery
act for exploitation of vulnerable
children and that local authorities
often don't warm police when at-risk
children are moved into an area and that
forty three separate police forces are
still not sharing intelligence
effectively with county lines offending
and other forms of offending they cross
boundaries they cross police force
boundaries the problem that's created by
the structure that we have now for
policing in England and Wales is that
you have barriers to the efficient
exchange of intelligence and information
between police forces autistic and
easily manipulated Clare's son
experienced what's called cuckooing
where dealers new to an area takeover a
vulnerable person's home she later
photographed the gang who were from
London they turned her son's flat in
Kent into a drug den after tricking
their way in by offering to sell him
cannabis so they've kind of walked up to
the door and then my son's gone indoors
and they just followed him in basically
so there's him in five gang members yeah
in the house with a dog the gang members
bring the dog yeah pitbull my son said
that they just literally took over and
he felt quite intimidated by them
because straightaway they pulled out a
knife put it on the side pulled out
their scales and obviously the drugs
that they had they said they were from
central London they've stabbed people
and they've done this so instantly he
felt quite vulnerable
and if caught you leave the scene Claire
describes is what we've found previously
here one drug users home in North London
is where a gang admitted they ran a
county line through violence and
intimidation you come on violet and step
on my toes you're shutting your face you
can stop doing it whatever they might
hear you are going a little play for a
coal mine anyone can get you step for my
toes yeah the contractor early grave the
police inspector it says coordinated
police operations where they target
gangs like this one in Essex are working
well but should be more focused on those
running the biggest most damaging
operations Jason Farrell Sky News